a couple months ago we looked back at
Old footage from my daily Vlog and I
already got what I wanted out of this
which was the fondness of looking back
at things I'm making a prediction that I
will look at this interview in 30 40 50
years with Incredible fondness and so I
have a feeling this will be an important
video that I watch and my grandkids
watch I dat trade attention and build
businesses Legacy is greater than
currency
I'm a pure bread entrepreneur for real
for real for real like
documented I'm literally Twitch
streaming in my office all day 90% of it
has no audio I unmute at times and say
what's up we do random fun stuff I wish
I was doing this when I was building
Wine Library I'd be unmuted the whole
time and I would be streaming for 12
hours a day if you're a lawyer in here
construction shop owner an accountant I
actually think you should be screaming
on Twitch and Tik Tok live your day I
think live streaming is in the same
place that social media was in 2014
which was it was known but it was
underestimated if you're podcasting live
stream on Twitch and Tik Tok
simultaneously and I couldn't recommend
more people get serious about that
twitch I had to tell you this Andrew
very smart marketer someone I've always
respected just did the first thing ever
I was 5 minutes late as you saw I was
wrapping up with the Sasha group and he
went on TW to see where the [__] I was
or what I was up to that's [__]
[Music]
amazing so Dustin's about you're about
to switch cameras we're setting up for
the podcast make sure you share this out
tell everybody in be friend's Discord
tell all your social medias we'll be
live here in 30 minutes got some big ass
guests it's going to be fun and have a
really good show that I think all of you
going to like we see in a little
bit I believe the world has gotten
really good at spitting
negativity real good negativity is loud
as [__] we're walking around 24/7
hearing how something's [__] up
everything super loud everyone's like
the algorithms [__] me up I'm like
you're the algorithm the algorithm is a
reflection of you I'll show you my
algorithm it's Jets football it's happy
kittens Onre like I got positivity in my
feed cuz I don't [__] with negativity
like that that [__] based on what you
what you
the Ali I [__] with that though that's
you the algorithm bro if I had any
musical Rhythm I'd be with you guys bro
I got bars I just don't know how to do
the music anyway I want to give some
flowers I'm going to give love to my
best friend Brandon wari who I met the
first day of high school and I sold him
some cards the next day but we became
best friends forever I've never said
this public I do not believe that I have
the career I have today if it wasn't for
Brandon Warick because I would have
never left my dad's store if it was
wasn't in his hands I could not be me
because I would have never left my dad
like that because I wouldn't have felt
good when we graduated college he came
in at 23 I worked with him every [__]
day 8:00 a.m. to 10: p.m. 350 days a
year for a decade he's family as much as
my brother and sister and I could have
never made that leap to the next place
if I didn't know I had somebody good
good cuz I my dad needed that partner
and I was that and that was the closest
thing and so that's my love big shout
out to Brandon War because I got to run
to my next [__] I'm gonna leave it with
what you just said my dude life is how
you see it if you wake up tomorrow and
say everything's [__] up I got news
for you that whole day you were going to
find [__] that is [__] up but if you
wake up and be like yo life is good like
I'm lucky I'm even a person let me try
to find some positivity you will find it
every this has been an hour of
positivity you just got to follow the
right [__] people anyway thank you
fellas love
you you too brother this next podcast
Chris Dixon one of the Pioneers in
investing in crypto it's going to be
amazing please leave a comment of what
you thought about that episode but more
importantly your one takeaway or your
favorite quote I think a lot about
filming myself over the last 15 20 years
and a couple months ago we looked back
at Old footage from my daily vog and I
already got what I wanted out of this
which was the fondness of looking back
at things I'm making a prediction that I
will look at this interview in 30 40 50
years with Incredible fondness and so I
have a feeling this will be important
video that I watch and my grandkids
watch one of our my partners he was
tweeting about it one of his family
members was had a phone call with his
voice with they using Ai and said hey I
need you to send me money and that
that's that's already here you can take
someone's snippet of their voice
replicate yeah replicate it so like
we're going to need system yeah imagine
this hello I'm in big trouble you need
to text me like it's G to yeah you leave
a voicemail so that people not going to
believe anything there's an answer to
this which is cryptography right which
is cryptography on blockchains you can
have systems build systems where you can
we have it we
like we walk around with aouch ID in our
pocket and it's not that hard to connect
that to a bunch of other systems
including blockchains to make sure that
we can authenticate video and text and
voice and all these other things and in
fact we have a bunch of like we were're
working with Sam Alman he's got a
startup called worldcoin which is
exactly that proof of personhood using
blockchain that was awesome thank you
that's going to be really good did you
like the so we covered and everything
okay okay like actually
and thank you so much for being part of
my one Club I love doing these videos
for you love the fact that so many of
you have discovered new wines and white
burgundy continues to be an explosion in
US demand and this next wine I think is
just remarkable soggy waffles 3 just
gifted tier one Subs to a bunch of
people there's ads when you watch on
Twitch Brandon you can get a paid
subscription to eliminate the ads but
people in the community can buy those
for people in the community it's like
the most Karma thing ever can you please
say soggy waffles 3 I love you soy
waffles 3 I love you thank you br all
right let's keep going on with the wine
of the month Club
show if anybody here sells anything
physically you should seriously get
educated on Tik Tok live and Tik Tok
shop because Tik Tok pushes live to the
algorithm Instagram does not so
Instagram it pings all your people that
follow you and that's why if you've gone
on Instagram live I've probably seen
like a 100 people come on and then very
quickly you see there's only 16 cuz it
declines cuz it's hard to retain Tik
tok's the reverse if you're on for four
hours you get seven on right away all of
a sudden you look up and you have a 100
that algorithmic Discovery is huge all
right everybody thank you so much for
hanging with me I'm giving away a vs
card right now on the spot the cgc 10
selfless sloth bombs stick said me first
comment too bomb stick very nice work
see you have a great night going to
dinner meetings all right Del have to
think today was super productive the
twitch stuff the meetings with clients
podcast with friends was amazing
there'll be a ton of clips from that
Chris Dixon right operating over
everything read it out to Booga we read
it out to boa that's awesome 2024 the
year of live streaming who just hit me
with the
raid is that actually Gary that's my guy
Gary I looked over it says Gary V is now
raiding you I'm like what yo Gary thank
you for the raid Man is real let's
go they got Gary on Twitch now they had
a podcast going okay I was wondering
what he'd be streaming day in the life
of a CEO in the mornings oh wait that's
actually fire mute during meetings and
puts on Old podcast videos so he streams
all day then right you know that's
actually interesting to watch because
Gary he is uh he's always doing
something